yeah it's some stand to see me ah I
never know quite what the answer to that
is I mean it I think I think the answer
is boringly obvious as it depends I mean
you know frankly just as we were
negotiating the Good Friday Agreement if
I come out and said to Ian Paisley and
by the way just before you go I've
decided become a Catholic well sure that
would have been an immensely positive
contribution to the process on the other
hand I think what being a person of
faith can do in it in a context in which
religious faith is an issue is it can
locate you as somebody who kind of
understands about faith so obviously it
depends what reputation your particular
brand of faith has right you could be
reputed to be as kind of fanatic in your
faith which obviously wouldn't be
helpful but if you I have never found a
problem either in the Northern Ireland
context in fact I found it mildly an
advantage to be known as generally a
person of faith and likewise I would say
in the Middle East now I don't put a lot
into that but I think also one
interesting thing about the world of
faith today is that people because
because the world of faith also feels
that it's very much under attack from
secularism if you are someone at faith
you kind of feel a connection with
someone at faith even if they're a
different faith III find so it can play
in that sense I think positive role -
but I mean Dan forts example in Sudan
was very interesting I thought in that
in that light because obviously that
gave him a position from which he was
able better to pursue politics of
reconciliation